RIPPED FROM TODAY'S INTERNET
HEADLINES, IT'S RAPID REFRESH!
>> NOW, WE HAVE SOME AMAZING
GUESTS AND SURPRISES ALL WEEK,
TO CELEBRATE OUR TRIP TO THE BIG
APPLE AND WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO REPLACE THE SEATS OF ALL THE
WOMEN IN THE AUDIENCE AFTER THIS
FIRST ONE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, JON HAMM!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, HE GETS IT!
>> BALLER ALERT.
>> Chris: YEP. YEP.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME, CHRIS.
I HEARD YOU WERE IN TOWN, I HAD
TO COME ON.
I AM SO EXCITED BECAUSE I AM
SUCH A HUGE FAN OF THE SHOW, OF
ALL YOU GUYS 0 AND OF ALL THINGS
INTERNET.
AND YOU KNOW WHY I LOVE THE
>> Chris: PORN?
>> NOT JUST GAY PORN, CHRIS.
>> Chris: I DIDN'T SAY EVERY
GAY PORN, I JUST SAID PORN.
I AM DRAWING A BLANK IF THERE
IS ANYTHING ELSE.
>> CATS, CHRIS, CATS!
>> Chris: OKAY, YEAH. CATS.
THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S GREAT.
NOW, DOGS MAY BE MAN'S BEST
FRIEND BUT CATS ARE CLEARLY
MAN'S BEST SNUGGLE BUDDY.
>> Chris: OH, OKAY.
SO GAY PORN.
BUT WHEN YOU TRY TO SNUGLING
A CAT DON'T YOU JUST END UP
LOOKING LIKE WOLVERINE ATTACKED
YOU?
>> THAT'S THE FUN OF IT.
I MEAN, THE INTERNET OFFERS SO
MANY VARIETY OF CATS.
THERE IS GRUMPY CAT.
THERE IS ANGRY CAT, THERE IS
CATS WITH TOP HATS.
AND THERE ARE CATS WITH CANES
AND CATS WITH 401-KS.
>> Chris: WHY WOULD THERE BE
CATS WITH RETIREMENT FUNDS?
>> CHRIS, THEY HAVE NINE LIVES.
>> Chris: OH, RIGHT. YEAH.
I AM SORRY.
>> THAT'S A LOT OF RETIREMENTS.
>> Chris: YEAH, NO. YOU'RE
RIGHT.
I'M SORRY. I'M STUPID.
I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT IT THAT
WAY.
HE IS RIGHT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU GUYS GET IT.
FORTUNATELY PLOTS OF CATS ARE
HARD WORKERS LIKE THE CATS THAT
HANG OUT IN SOME OF NEW YORK'S
FINEST BODEGAS.
THEY WATCH OVER AISLES OF
EXPIRED MAYONNAISE, GUATEMALAN
TOOTHPASTE AND OFF BRAND SPANISH
FLY.
AND THEY ARE FEATURED ON THE
FANTASTIC BODEGA CATS TUMBLR.
SO COMEDIANS, WHICH OF THESE
PICTURES ON THE BODEGA CATS
TUMBLR GOT THE MOST VOTES.
>> A, THIS LITTLE KITKAT.
>> Chris: OH, GOO, GA, GA.
>> HE'S A PIECE OF CANDY!
>> Chris: I WILL SPIT IT UP FOR
HALLOWEEN.
>> SPIT IT OUT?
>> SO HE CAN EAT IT AGAIN.
>> OH, OKAY.
B, THIS CAT BOMBED OUT ON THE
BEER DELIVERY.
OR C THIS CAT THAT LOOKS A
LOT LIKE DON DRAPER DID MOST OF
LAST SEASON.
>> Chris: NIKKI.
>> I AM GOING WITH C, JON,
BECAUSE I JUST WANT TO TALK TO
YOU.
>> OKAY.
THE CORRECT ANSWER IS, IN FACT,
C.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: AND NIKKI DID GET TO
TALK TO JON HAMM.
>> OKAY, NOW COMEDIANS.
FOR BONUS POINTS GIVE ME A TWEET
FROM THIS HUNG OVER BODEGA CAT.
>> Chris: NIKKI.
>> GOT SO DRUNK LAST NIGHT I
TOOK SOME RANDOM CHILDLESS WOMAN
HOME.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JOHN MULANEY.
>> HELP I AM ON THE TOP SHELF,
GET THAT LONG BODEGA STICK WITH
THE HORSESHOE ON THE END OF IT.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JUDAH FRIEDLANDER.
>> OF ALL THE DAYS TO GET
HUNGOVER, I GOT TO RIP-UP THREE
COUCHES BY NOON AND (BLEEP) ON
THE PILLOW.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
EXCELLENT!
A HUGE HAND FOR JON HAMM,
EVERYONE.
BY THE WAY, BY THE WAY, I
WOULD LIKE TO SINCERELY THANK
YOU FROM TAKING A BREAK FROM
YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE TO COME PLAY
WITH US.
>> CHRIS, I ALWAYS BRAKE FOR
CATS.